so has it kind of sunk in the success of
this film and the reaction to this yeah
are you been watching and reading and
people's reaction to it yes people send
me stuff i read stuff but yeah as the
days go on you're starting to get a
feeling that it went really well um
because yeah sometimes it doesn't and
you feel that also so but uh yeah no
i've loved the reaction i was just
talking to vigo about it i don't think
it could have gone better yeah so it's
up for interpretation this film
is there something that you read that
you're just a nice way to say it
i don't know because i keep asking
everyone like what has happened and the
character and nobody's telling me yeah
yeah yeah even what happens to your
character like what why
why why that happens right like well i
know why it happens
well i can't say or i give away the
whole plot of the ending of the movie
right you can't say
can you say no yeah
oh yeah you have to see it you have to
go see it yeah so okay so the craziest
interpretation of it yeah uh do you want
my craziest introduction
have you read anything that you thought
like it's completely no no the stuff i
read i really haven't read that many
reviews i just i basically check to see
if they're positive or negative and then
i move on but yeah no i haven't really
read any fan reactions or anything like
that yeah now have you talked to david
after the film being shown in ken and
how's he feeling and
his response to it yeah kind of honestly
maybe even freaked out how well it went
you know he's used to a little more up
and down and being a little more
divisive so he's he's thrilled i think
it's overwhelming to him that it's been
so well received no it's the 20th
anniversary of underworld oh wow what is
it 22 oh that's terrifying i know it's
been that can you believe it's been that
long yeah it seems like a long time ago
you're supposed to say no i don't know
and some stuff feels like a long time
ago but underworld is like that that
feels like a long time ago
the first one to you though right what's
that it was so important to you huge
yeah i was just coming off a tv show i
hadn't done a movie that really popped
commercially and yeah that was a big one
for me i love that yeah are you looking
forward to working with david again i
would love to yeah i mean he's he's
ready to go man he's got a couple of
movies he's doing so yeah i would love
to work with him again congratulations
good seeing you again